US Customs and Border Protection is
doing medical exams on thousands of
children in its custody after the death
of a second migrant child this month
homeland security secretary Kirsten
Nielsen says the immigration system has
been pushed to a breaking point she says
more than 68,000 families in close to
14,000 unaccompanied children have come
to the southern border in the past two
months seeking refuge Janet shamlian is
near the border in El Paso Texas with
more Janet good morning good morning the
holding centers here at the border are
clearly overwhelmed in the case of that
eight-year-old boy who died in US
custody he was first detained here in
the US then transferred to New Mexico
because of the overcrowding situation
his death now raising concerns about the
ability of border agents to care for the
thousands of migrants who are now trying
to emigrate to the United States they're
fleeing poverty they're fleeing violence
they're coming to our country for help
congresswoman elect Veronica Escobar
says the death of Guatemalan native
Phillipe Alonzo Gomez was another
tragedy waiting to happen
Phillippe and his father were
apprehended here in El Paso an urban
area where there is significant access
to clinics to physicians to hospitals he
was transported from an area with
resources to an area with fewer
resources the eight-year-old died from
flu-like symptoms after being treated
then released from a hospital less than
three weeks after the death of seven
year old Jacqueline call who died from
dehydration and shock both deaths are
being investigated Homeland Security
Kirsten Nielsen called the immigration
system one that prevents parents who
bring their children on a dangerous
illegal journey from facing consequences
for their actions
she mandated the medical checks of all
children in US custody and will travel
to the border this week to tour the
facilities this is an extraordinarily
rare occurrence it's been more than a
decade since we've had a child pass away
anywhere in a CBP process
CBP commissioner Kevin McHale inan
appeared on CBS this morning yesterday
he's now asking for more help from
Congress our stations are not built for
that group that's crossing today there
they were built 3040 years ago for
single adult males and we need a
different approach Aaron curry is one of
1,100 nurse volunteers deployed by
National Nurses United to help at the
border I haven't seen a child without
congestion in a cough the group calling
on the Trump administration to
immediately end its practice of
warehousing families and children
they're malnourished they're dehydrated
and they're scared
also straining a system the number of
migrants who are being dropped off by
authorities at the El Paso bus station
they have no money and the shelters the
charitable ones that have been taking
them in are now overflowing themselves
by some accounts more than 700 have been
released since Sunday many with no place
to go such a tough situation Janet thank
you